no
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros comenzamos
hoy les traemos un documental que
investiga lo que pasó días previos al
atentado del 11 de septiembre en eeuu
hace 20 años y todo lo que ocurrió en
las últimas dos décadas lo primero fue
el asesinato por parte de al qaeda dos
días antes de los atentados del líder de
la resistencia afgana el comandante a
mahatma su principal obstáculo de osama
bin laden quien sabía que este
comandante podría ser aliado de eeuu
después de los ataques del 11-s
precisamente más sur había advertido
varias veces a occidente sobre las
amenazas de al-qaeda pero no hubo eco
luego de los atentados vino la invasión
estadounidense a afganistán y al no
poder convencer a los talibanes de
separarse de al qaeda que tenía una base
en este país
washington lo sacó por la fuerza hoy 20
años después retomaron el control del
país dos años después del 11-s otro
objetivo estadounidense se abrió en la
región acabar con las armas de
destrucción masiva en irak país al que
se consideró cómplice de los atentados
del 11-s en el siguiente documental de
antoine mariotto y periodista de france
veremos entre otros a partes clave de la
historia cuál fue la actuación de la cia
antes y después de los atentados y por
qué no se hizo caso a las advertencias
de la resistencia afgana y finalmente
cómo cambió la estrategia estadounidense
después de la caída de las torres
gemelas está la historia
[Música]
y fue lo primero en lo que pensamos fue
en alcaide al qaida
se entendía la amenaza pero no
encabezaba la lista de prioridades
mangini boris por world west
guardia
sufrimos una gran pérdida medio nuestro
duelo de nuestra ira
hemos encontrado nuestra misión y
nuestro momento
pondremos unos tipos en un helicóptero y
volveremos mañana a afganistán way
desafortunadamente sabemos cómo invadir
país
muchos talibanes fueron asesinados pero
la mayoría se
disperse a donde fuerte dale
[Música]
todos sus bienes decidieron vivir en
negación
eventualmente se verán obligados a vivir
con miedo
y tuvimos razón
o estoy horrorizado de haber sido parte
de eso es un desastre geopolítico mayor
y nunca debimos haber permitido que se
estableciera el califato
[Música]
el león del panshir icono de la
resistencia afgana
[Música]
en su valle el comandante masud recorría
la línea de frente con los talibanes y
recibía a los periodistas extranjeros
el 9 de septiembre de 2001 se
presentaron ante él dos reporteros harás
[Música]
siempre lo estábamos siguiendo para
tener muchos archivos de imagen
en ellas
ese día yo tenía mi propia cámara y sólo
quería grabar la entrevista en esto
antes éramos cuatro personas yo a otro
amigo y esos dos árabes en mi a nadar
friend in these tracks
de liderazgo el líder les pregunto
quiénes ser
cómo habían llegado a afganistán a qué
tipo de preguntas tenis y al menos una
de las preguntas era si toma el control
de afganistán qué hará con el líder de
al-qaeda osama bin laden
yo estaba ocupado con mi cámara tal vez
durante 15 20 30 segundos
la explosión del marido no fue muy
fuerte como cuando estalla un balón de
fútbol y se explotó
teniendo voltea mirar el edificio vi que
todas las puertas y las ventanas se
habían estallado y que había un
la cámara de los falsos periodistas
escapó a la vigilancia de los guardias
los dos hombres que eran en realidad
miembros de al qaeda habían escondido
allí una carga explosiva
yo estaba con mi abuela estaba sentado
con ella y estábamos comiendo
también estaba con nosotros
tome una cuchara para comer y
cayó de la mano y de repente sintiendo
descarga de estrés y adrenalina venas y
realmente me asusté mucho
me pregunto qué te pasas really
así que le dije que no sabía pero que
tenía un sentimiento extraño de que algo
le había pasado a mi padre hay uno de
gentes es un feeling santana punto mejor
en el momento exacto del ataque y de la
situación a cientos de miles de
kilómetros de ese lugar en el que yo
estaba
[Música]
aterrizó
vimos el edificio del hospital hemos que
había otro edificio a la distancia que
era la morgue
del carro
tiro hacia la morgue en ese momento ya
no estaba vivo
[Aplausos]
a pesar de la pérdida de su emblemático
jefe los principales responsables de la
alianza del norte lograron mantener la
unidad del movimiento
los demás debieron enfrentar el avance
del talibán que ya controlaba casi todo
el país
[Música]
una al qaeda pensaba aprovechar la
situación para poder tener una especie
de base permanente en afganistán de
saturación se
forman en beige en
biología
los métodos serán más o menos los mismos
lo que el mundo todavía no sabía
es que el asesinato de masud era tan
solo la primera etapa
[Música]
la especial total en américa
y su suave deliberemos justicia la tuvo
[Música]
al levantar la vista un poco antes de
las nueve y una inmensa nube de humo
llame de inmediato a mis colaboradores y
estábamos ahí comentando lo que nos
parecía ser un accidente gravísimo
sucio cuando vimos un segundo avión
[Aplausos]
y en ese momento entendimos que no se
trataba de un accidente sino que eeuu
estaba siendo atacado que estaba en
guerra
[Música]
de inmediato que a miami responsable de
contrainteligencia y me dijo que
estábamos siendo atacados
unos dos minutos después de amor el
vicepresidente y dijo que por favor
bajaremos a la sala de conferencia
asegurada
debíamos tener una videollamada wake up
pero ahí mismo me di cuenta que tras el
asesinato de
eeuu sin duda yo
éramos culpables por tener falta de
imaginación
desde hacía años basura el afgano había
tratado de advertirle a los occidentales
acerca de la amenaza de al-qaida
lo repetía sin cesar como lo hizo
durante su visita al parlamento europeo
de estrasburgo a principios de 2001 o
también aquí durante una de sus últimas
entrevistas un mes antes de su muerte
si osama bin laden no está ocupado en
afganistán creo que causará muchos
estragos en el exterior
y eso sí por supuesto que andaban
escuchando pero no tomaron ninguna
medida innovación' en el valle de
panchir se entendió muy pronto que esos
atentados contra eeuu estaban
relacionados con afganistán
de las personas responsables por el 9/11
son las mismas personas responsables por
el asesinato de mi padre
esos dos árabes
enter a vertir y chip entraron en
nuestro territorio casi 15 días antes
del 9 de septiembre
eso significa que el plan to ashes en et
era asesinar al líder mucho antes del 9
acción día before night on september
lograban hacer eso
tendrían suficiente tiempo para limpiar
afganistán under the 9/11
declina la falsa
before the nine el rap
pero fue interesante cuando
fue asaltado y talibán estaba eufórico
pensaban que eso había sido todo eso
finalmente
etc
el principal bastión de resistencia
contra los talibanes y al qaeda no había
sido derrotado era una piedra en el
zapato para osama bin laden que sabía
perfectamente que en su respuesta eeuu
podría contar con esos antiguos soldados
de masur en el seno de la cia unos
agentes trataron desesperadamente
durante los años siguientes de convertir
a al qaeda en la autoridad de la
investigación estadounidense pero él
langridge la sede de la agencia la
dirección no les prestó atención
[Música]
algo reclusión una fuente que era
miembro de al qaeda
reclutamos por completo
trabajo para nosotros y luego de repente
fue obligado por órdenes del cuartel
general de la cia a cortar todo contacto
con él y dejar de reunirme con él
básicamente porque eran ciudadanos de un
país con el cual teníamos relaciones
amistosas y estábamos más preocupados de
que descubrieran que estábamos
encontrándonos con este tipo y de que
eso pudiera dañar eventualmente las
relaciones diplomáticas de lo que
estaban por tener una fuente dentro de
al qaeda entonces tuve que acortar el
contacto
al qaeda hacía parte de los objetivos de
washington desde hacía años el grupo
llevó a cabo ataques contra las
embajadas estadounidenses en kenia y
tanzania en 1998 y contra la vida
estadounidense cole en el 2000
[Música]
los espías estadounidenses detectaron a
osama bin laden en varias ocasiones
cuando estaban afganistán hubo planes
operacionales completos redactados en la
agencia central de inteligencia para ir
a afganistán y acabar con él
la original era que íbamos a ir a que
están y vamos a matar a ese tipo porque
estaba preparándose para matarnos a
nosotros picados porque en realidad ya
nos estaba matando
y esos planes nunca se aprobaron y él
estaba ahí con su familia llevará a cabo
esa operación habría causado la muerte
de mujeres y nápoles después del 11 de
septiembre la estrategia estadounidense
cambió radicalmente ya no hubo más
sentimentalismos o medidas a medias
[Música]
quiero que sepan que hoy eeuu se
arrodilla para rezar por las personas
que perdieron sus vidas aquí
los escucho el resto del mundo los
escuchas
[Aplausos]
y las personas que nos derribaron pronto
nos escucharán
al día siguiente del 9/11 en las 24 o 48
horas siguientes ya estaba de regreso en
el cuartel general de la cia
había mucha arranco
seguida rápidamente por un ok
ya podemos quitarnos los guantes podemos
ir a hacer todas las cosas que hemos
tratado de que nos dejen de hacer
mike leigh es demasiado tarde hay miles
de muertos pero podemos finalmente
comprar nos de estantes menos de 48
horas después de los atentados asia
trató desesperadamente de infiltrar a la
organización terrorista lo más pronto
posible para obtener informaciones y
poder acabar con ellos algunos se
acordaron entonces de la antigua fuente
de san félix sanz briz de hecho alguien
del centro de contraterrorismo vino a
hablar conmigo y me preguntó si yo sabía
cómo podía ponerse en contacto con ese
tipo y donde podíamos encontrar
lo cual era una pregunta ridícula era un
terrorista no era un amigo no era mi
hermano no manteníamos un contacto
social en qantas y nunca supo mi
verdadero nombre por supuesto y no nos
sale con las fuentes terroristas no les
envías tarjeta de navidad dónde estás si
pudiera adivinar el día que está en
alguna parte organizando operaciones
para matar estadounidenses eso es lo que
pienso
tenemos una gran agencia de inteligencia
pero todavía no somos la mejor
inteligencia del mundo porque porque no
tenemos que hacerlo no somos los
ingleses no estamos siendo atacados por
todos los frentes
solución una sociedad libre demócrata
abierta con una frontera abierta al sur
por favor que podría salir mal y de
repente nos damos cuenta de que el mal
insiste
y si tanto los demócratas como los
republicanos no le prestaron suficiente
atención a la amenaza terrorista fue
porque esa época parecía muy tranquila
y hay que recordar que en los 90
estábamos celebrando de verdad y los
dividendos de la paz
recortamos drásticamente el
financiamiento para nuestra entidad de
inteligencia
es verdad que la caída del bloque
soviético
y blogs
el final de la parte identidad africana
de la partida a la frente
la idea de que llegaríamos a un acuerdo
entre los palestinos y los israelíes en
el proceso de paz
llevado a cabo por rabín y arafat
que crearon durante una cierta cantidad
de meses largos meses
más bien optimista y optimista
el 11 de septiembre fue el fin de un
período breve que no llamaría de euforia
pero sí dio tranquilidad internacional
de repente wow no teníamos suficientes
personas que hablaran no teníamos
suficientes personas que hablaban persa
no teníamos a nadie que hablara y aleuy
no asignado teníamos suficiente de lo
que necesitábamos sí estoy en lo
correcto usted dice todo eso y quiere
decir que los ataques del 11 de
septiembre eran evitables sin duda
algunas absolutamente evitables
eeuu descubrió sus errores el golpe de
los ataques todavía no había pasado pero
ya era hora de la venganza
nuestro dolor se convirtió en rabia y la
rabia en resolución
la justicia
la justicia a nuestros enemigos se hará
justicia evitan la primera decisión que
era darle al talibán una oportunidad
para que entregar a osama bin laden
y el primer mensaje para el talibán en
afganistán fue si lo hacen pueden
permanecer en el poder tenían un plazo
muy corto
claro que no iban a entregar a ninguno
de los líderes de al-qaeda
así que inevitablemente después de eso
hubo acciones
y por supuesto occidente no podía
entenderlo
eso lo vio en eso lo entiendo un acto
salvaje y
paciente una bestia salvaje que hay que
hacer así matarla no se trata de ponerse
a pensar porque mordió
en toda nación en cada región ahora
tiene que tomar una decisión
y no están con nosotros
yo están con los terroristas
[Música]
los escombros seguían humeando menos de
10 días después de los atentados del 11
de septiembre jacques chirac fue el
primer jefe de estado extranjero en
llegar al lugar de los hechos
una visita prevista desde hacía tiempo y
la cual el presidente estadounidense
procuró mantener el mensaje era claro
eeuu sufrió pero sigue de pie su entrada
a chirac lo dijo el presidente
estadounidense que estábamos listos para
iniciar ya toda nuestra ayuda y equipo
en táchira que le dio el presidente bush
que había sólo una cosa que no le podía
pedir eso sí eran operaciones como sí es
decir asesinatos dirigidos los asesinos
y de el presidente bush se sorprendió
mucho
una para lo que no se sentía que esa
administración
fuera utilizar ese horror para llevar a
cabo guerras de gran amplitud o para
emprender aventuras militares
era claro cuando uno es posible decir
claramente que resultó que los esas
instancias que iban a resolver por sí
mismos debido era evidente
muy pronto se perfiló una operación en
afganistán
fue en ese país gobernado por el talibán
donde al qaeda instaló su base de
retaguardia
[Música]
eeuu primero si giro hacia el pakistán
vecino dirigido por el general musharraf
fue uno de los pocos países en el mundo
en apoyar al talibán para mantener un
cierto control en el país así islamabad
compró la paz en su lado oeste entre las
tensiones eran recurrentes con india en
el este el 11 de septiembre de 2001 el
general ma cut ahmad jefe de los
servicios de inteligencia militares
paquistaníes se encontraba de visita en
washington
quería explicarme que yo debía entender
la historia del talibán y no se daban
en lo general la historia empieza hoy
estoy aquí son seis o siete peticiones
que el secretario powell y yo escribimos
en un papel que se lo dimos y le dijimos
por favor póngase en contacto con el
presidente mussara hablé con él acerca
de esto
necesitábamos que nos dijera que si lee
a todos
no un sí
a
ver que no quería hacer
llevé a mi oficina donde tenía exhibido
una estrella
en un reconocimiento que me dieron
durante la guerra abierta por apoyar a
los murió a ginés de palmesana
pero la estrella paquistaní
y si usted no acepta nuestras funciones
ningún estadounidense volverá a recibir
una de estas hay se lo prometo al día
siguiente llegó y dijo que el presidente
mejoraba había estado de acuerdo con
todo la versión de que el general
musharraf ha dado este mensaje
transmitido por el general mahmud era o
están con nosotros solo par de haremos
de regreso
y en los meses siguientes puedo decirle
que mi relación con el isi el servicio
de inteligencia de pakistán y dio un
giro de 180 grados y dicen cualquier
cosa que quisiéramos en relación con al
qaeda nos la daban de wilco operábamos
de manera muy muy cercana pero esas
mismas reglas no avisaron
la inteligencia estadounidense logró
entrar en contacto con el mulá osman y
un adjunto del mulá omar el fundador del
talibán robert kenner jefe de la sede de
la cia en la región se reunió con él
el espía quería convencerlo de que
dejara ir a bin laden
hizo algo que nunca había visto que un
líder tribal pastún hiciera se quitó la
vestimenta del turbante y los puso en la
mesa al lado de él y parecía desesperado
porque sabía antes ante que les esperaba
centraban en guerra con ellos resumidos
víboras
y dijo díganme qué debería hacer
entonces le dije mire sabemos que el
mulá omar por muchas razones no puede
acordar relaciones comunes pero usted
puede hacer lo que el mulá omar no puede
le corresponde a usted salvar el mal
mientras nadie está diciendo que debería
casar al mulá omar se debe ponerlo bajo
arresto domiciliario debe hacer una
declaración pública inmediatamente lo
que está haciendo porque necesita el
apoyo de la ayuda y por supuesto
repasamos todo con detalle aunque él me
escuchó dijo ok
fue como si se le quitara un peso de
encima luego se subió en su vehículo y
se fueron de regreso a kandahar
yo esperaba en contra de todo pronóstico
que su resolución sobreviviera hasta
llevar a kandahar pero tenía que no
ocurriera de hecho no ocurrió
sin poder convencer a los talibanes de
abandonar al qaeda washington se preparó
para sacarlos del poder a la fuerza
donald rumsfeld el secretario de defensa
preparó el pentágono para la ofensiva
pero los militares afirman que el largo
tiempo de preparación para ir a un país
tan lejano y complicado no permitió
actuar tan rápido como lo hubiera
querido george w.bush
él estaba furioso con el ejército por no
ser capaz de desplegar una gran cantidad
de fuerzas en afganistán a tiempo kabul
estaba listo para caer y nosotros no
teníamos a nadie ahí y la actitud era
que pondríamos unos tipos en un
helicóptero por haríamos afganistán
mañanas no importa nada
no necesitamos cientos de hombres
así fue como empezó la invasión a un
viejo helicóptero ruso y unos ocho tipos
de la cia que se fueron con bolsas
llenas de dinero para hablar con un
montón de líderes tribales
afortunadamente habíamos mantener el
contacto
pero cuando las tribus locales supuestas
al tal iván hubieron desembarcar las
maletas llenas de dólares de la cia y
luego a las fuerzas especiales
estadounidenses entendieron que
washington estaba decidido a ir hasta el
final los combates empezaron con el
apoyo aéreo de eeuu que bombardearon las
posiciones de los talibanes la alianza
del norte progreso rápidamente al
movimiento del célebre comandante masud
asesinado dos días antes del 11 de
septiembre parecían haber nacido alas
aprobación de los estadounidenses
entraron a kabul la capital
[Música]
caguas se había convertido en un lugar
de odio a definición de las actividades
injustas que los talibanes habían hecho
durante años
y si no hubiéramos entrado en cabo
intentar cobol a las personas podrían
haber tenido deseos de venganza con kirk
y chabán y finalmente habría podido
hacer un baño de sangre
y tratar de que el talibán no pudiera
regresar al país
la operación militar y la operación de
la cia que derrotó al talibán y se tomó
a bulto cabo es probablemente la
operación militar estadounidense más
brillante desde la segunda guerra
mundial con hecha de manera perfecta en
mi opinión muy pocos estadounidenses y
ese apoyo aéreo de eeuu por aliados
tribales y el talibán quedó destruido
el comienzo fue bastante sencillo
desafortunadamente sabemos cómo invadir
a
los miembros de al qaeda se habían
escondido en las montañas afganas la
casa blanca quería evitar un vacío de
poder y que el país se hundiera en el
caos
varios estados extranjeros aceptaron
intervenir militarmente en afganistán
jacques chirac en especial mantuvo su
palabra
pero él y su primer ministro leo en el
spa siguieron siendo prudentes
por y social
esencialmente atacaríamos con nuestros
aviones desde un portaaviones que
habíamos desplegado en el mediterráneo
durante un tiempo desplegamos fuerzas
especiales
pero en general
en acuerdo por el presidente de la
república en esa época
limitamos nuestras intervenciones al
aseguramiento de nuestra embajada y ya
la sede de las naciones unidas en kabul
que había vuelto a abrir
así fue al menos mientras yo estuve en
el gobierno hasta 2002 así que no
entramos al engranaje militar afgano
lo que se debe decir es que una cierta
cantidad de países han llegaban ahí para
combatir bat
en alemania era una de las dificultades
que teníamos con ellos pero no sólo con
alemana tenían restricciones
seamos francos en afganistán los
soldados de la otan eran como unos
extras para los estadounidenses que es
importante ver que no estaban solos que
no era
que había de todo el occidente es
impulsado detrás eeuu
algunos aprovecharon la calma después de
la caída del talibán para involucrarse
lo menos posible pero la calma que
reinaba en afganistán era precaria
en 2002 2003 después de 2004 la
situación estaba mejorando era posible
viajar desde aquí hasta cualquier parte
del país no había ningún distrito bajo
el control
pero aunque los estadounidenses
progresaron en afganistán algunos
miembros de la administración tenían
desde hacía mucho tiempo otra idea en la
cabeza una idea que empezaron a
manifestar durante las horas que
siguieron al 11 de septiembre
unos días después de los atentados el
presidente george w.bush reunió a sus
principales responsables de seguridad el
secretario de defensa donald rumsfeld
llegó acompañado de un tal paul
wolfowitz
los diputados y otros nos habíamos ido
pero wolfowitz hoy habló delante del
presidente diciendo que utilizar esto
como una oportunidad para irán y el
presidente sencillo hacia el consejero
de seguridad y dijo quién es ese y él le
dijo que era el secretario adjunto de
defensa y él dijo bueno dígale que se
calle no quiero seguirlo escuchando
estamos concentrados en afganistán
[Música]
dos semanas después el congreso
finalmente nombró a john negroponte como
embajador ante la onu en el intervalo
wolfowitz y sus consortes lograron
establecer a irak como un tema de
preocupación para el presidente
en su primer día en el cargo a
negroponte se le asignó una tarea
inesperada
me dieran instrucciones de buscar al
embajador de irak en naciones unidas
para leerle unos puntos de discusión
y luego me entregaron unos puntos muy
severos para el embajador de irak que
básicamente decían
si está pensando en aprovecharse de
nuestra preocupación actual con
afganistán
puede estar seguro de que tomaremos
medidas muy severas en su contra
uy
efe
era un mensaje muy amenazante
esto era octubre de 2001
y esta administración ya estaba pensando
en irak
francamente creo que estaban buscando
maneras de culpar a irak por lo que
había pasado
la advertencia estadounidense se coló en
la prensa pero pasó un poco
desapercibida el mundo tenía sus ojos
puestos en afganistán donde los
talibanes eran sacados del poder por
estados unidos y sus aliados locales sin
embargo tras bambalinas la
administración bush estaba poniendo en
marcha serios preparativos el año 2002
acababa de empezar cuando en langley en
la sede de la cia sand fadis quedó
encargado de montar un equipo un poco
particular la decisión ya había sido
tomada por el presidente de eeuu bus de
kimba diríamos wilding red
y no dijo que tal vez fuéramos a invadir
o que si había armas de destrucción
masiva y vamos a embargo la decisión se
había tomado y vamos a invadir
así que mi trabajo era llevar el primer
equipo para preparar la invasión de irak
grace jon faddis y sus hombres fueron
los primeros estadounidenses en
desembarcar en suelo iraquí en el verano
de 2002 mucho antes que las fuerzas
especiales eran sólo 8 a su llegada pero
en el curso de los meses el equipo se
reforzó cerca de 50 agentes se
encontraban en kurdistán y recorrieron
de arriba a abajo todo el país en busca
de armas de destrucción masiva
para mediados de 2002
no cabía la menor duda de que había un
plan de invasión
sin embargo yo seguimos tratando de
evitar la guerra buscando tener una
resolución final de la una
en particular francia alemania y rusia
se opusieron a una entrada en guerra sin
una razón válida
la resolución negociada con eeuu
permitió ganar tiempo y hacer que
regresará los inspectores de la onu a
irak para verificar si sadam husein
tenía o no armas de destrucción masiva
para discurso del vicepresidente
estadounidense time
y
se nos dijo unas cuantas cosas
entre las cosas que me sorprendieron un
poco dijo que no dudaría en desacreditar
los en favor del desarme
pero luego nos dimos cuenta de que no
era que no encontrábamos y no
desenterrar a sus armas ellos bien nos
llevarían a cabo el desarme en irán
hans blix y su equipo de inspectores
recorrieron irak visitaron los lugares
sospechosos e incluso palacios del rais
sin encontrar el menor rastro de esas
famosas armas
las armas químicas no son mermelada
así que debían existir pruebas de eso
pero cuando llegamos al palacio de sadam
en una de nuestras inspecciones
revisamos todo el lugar y los
inspectores también los refrigeradores
sólo encontraron mermelada no había
armas químicas debajo de las mermeladas
para los franceses era demasiado eeuu
estaba tratando de legitimar su probable
entrada en guerra a través de una nueva
resolución de la onu pero parís amenazó
con utilizar su derecho al veto
entonces el quiebre una semana después
dominical para se expresó vivamente
delante de las naciones unidas francia
es un viejo país
de un viejo continente como el mío con
lo que lo
sabe todo lo que le debe a los
combatientes de la libertad llegados de
américa de madrid
fiel a sus valores quiere actuar de
manera resuelta con todos los miembros
de la comunidad internacional minute
internacional y cree en nuestra
capacidad para construir juntos un mundo
mejor
ustedes lo saben jamás aplaudimos en el
consejo de seguridad los aplausos fueron
espontáneos sentimos algo sentimos que
algo estaba pasando es cierto que ese
día francia fue la voz fue la voz de una
gran parte del mundo y eso no era
insignificante y ese disco benéfico ese
magnífico discurso fue visto en
washington como una cachetada
con mi papel me llamó a su oficina
diciéndome querido john davidson
trate de ayudarles para defender la
causa de la razón delante de los demás
es decir delante del vicepresidente dick
cheney dijo
el ministro de defensa donald rumsfeld
pero ahora estoy carbonizado estoy
carbonizado
él nunca nos dijo nada que no fuera
cierto para mí fue una sorpresa
y le di el crédito tuvo el valor de
decirnos eso a todos
en el seno de la administración bush dos
bandos se opusieron los que iban a la
guerra llevados por el vicepresidente
dick cheney y el secretario de defensa
donald rumsfeld y los partidarios de la
negociación encabezados por colin powell
y su equipo lawrence wilkerson recibió
un día la visita de un coronel del
pentágono muy contrariado y dijo bueno
ellos creen que ustedes son espías
espías espías para quien
sencillamente no les gusta su jefe el
secretario powell ha bueno entonces me
está diciendo que no podemos seguir
hablando
'queremos hablar' me dijo el coronel
necesitamos hablar pero el secretario de
defensa nos dijo que no podíamos
me di cuenta de que parte de eso una
gran parte era que estaban hablando
sobre siria sobre irak y sobre irán y
que estaban haciendo planes para esos
países y no querían que nos enteráramos
de eso
a finales de enero de 2003 colin powell
llegó a la casa blanca para reunirse con
su adjunto en el séptimo piso del
departamento de estado george bush
acababa de informarle que debería
pronunciar un discurso delante del
consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas para presentar las pruebas
estadounidenses
la oficina del vicepresidente acababa de
entregarle un informe completo
así se dijo francamente perdóneme pero
esto se ve muy mal
y dijo que iría la cia
revisando cada información de
inteligencia
para asegurarse que se sostendrían
powell acompañado por su fiel jefe de
gabinete pasó una semana en lang donde
el director de la cia george tenet puso
a sus agentes a su disposición
cuando llegue allá no tenía a un experto
profesional de inteligencia que les dirá
dioses tenet que se pudiera estás
equivocado yo no siempre déjame decirte
porque estás equivocado si fui a la cia
y vivía ahí durante unos seis días y
seis noches mi equipo era un redactor de
discursos león davidson barril o huitrón
un antiguo miembro del consejo de
inteligencia nacional y el primer día
george se negó a dar cualquier acceso a
los computadores de la silla así que
llamé a barrio y le dije barrio todavía
tienes tu tarjeta todavía funciona me
dijo no lo sé probemos se sentó delante
del computador y ingresó y bingo todavía
tenía acceso y sin sacarle el dedo a
tenet y tu imagen sesión computadora una
campera
durante una semana se examinó cada
información el equipo del secretario de
estado dejó muchas de lado la víspera
del discurso delante del consejo de
seguridad power the net y sus equipos se
encontraron en nueva york en el último
piso de la representación estadounidense
de la onu el secretario de estado se
preparó para leer por primera vez la
totalidad del discurso en voz alta
y dejó de hablar y la sala estaba en
completo silencio yo estaba sentado a su
izquierda se mete a su derecha
en internet pero su cabeza hacia george
tenet y dice george
y garantiza que todo en esta
presentación es lo mejor que puedes
hacer presión
y tener domino y le dijo si lo juro
entonces pongo él dijo bien porque vas a
estar detrás mío mañana delante de las
llamadas se abre
[Música]
hussein y su régimen están ocupados
haciendo todo lo posible para asegurar
que los inspectores no encuentren
absolutamente nada me inclina hacia
dominique de bilbao y le dije que aquí
en esta sala nadie creía lo que él decía
y tal vez ni siquiera el mismo el sat
crossing from the table me senté en
frente de él en la mesa y me acuerdo muy
bien de sentirme particularmente
escéptico al respecto de outlets
para nada con nuestra experiencia
estigmatizamos lo que nuestras fuentes
habían reportado sobre esas
instalaciones móviles aquí se ven
laboratorios móviles montados en
camiones y vagones sabemos cómo se ven
los fermentadores sabemos cómo se ven
los tanques las bombas los compresores y
las demás piezas
como sabían eso quién les dijo esas
cosas y por qué no podíamos encontrar
nada de eso estábamos ahí todo el día
todos los días mes tras mes tras mes
trabajando en ese momento con cientos de
fuentes pero no encontrábamos nada
yo les puedo asegurar que no tiene
intenciones de engañar a nadie no había
intenciones de engañar
james siempre
simplemente estaba actuando a partir de
información errónea e incorrecta e
interact information
y se
dice que es una mancha en su carrera que
nunca se borrará en nuestra vida
ya saben no me arrepiento de nada
el si sea revés
la administración bush no se conformó
con ese discurso de colin powell sus
principales actores trataban de
convencer a sus interlocutores en cada
oportunidad que había
dispuesto a ver con sueldo me acuerdo de
una reunión de ministros de la otan con
amstrong llegó con fotografías diciendo
tengo la prueba de velocidad que se
están preparando para lanzar misiles que
potencialmente a sus misiles nucleares
de hecho justo antes de que me fuera
nuestros servicios de inteligencia me
habían dado unas fotos tomadas por de
nuestros satélites franceses de ese
mismo sitio en un ángulo un poco
diferente y en ese momento yo saqué las
fotos y dije señor secretario de estado
mire son silos de maíz hubo un silencio
inmenso él estaba loco de rabia se
sentía se veía
entonces a que unas profetas diciendo
miren aquí adentro hay unos virus de no
sé qué cosa que trajimos de irak lo cual
evidentemente era igual de falso le
pregunté a mi vecino italiano creo que
estaba al lado
qué hago lo dejo pasar para que lo vean
los dirigentes de la cia se basaron en
el testimonio de una fuente de servicios
alemanes llamada 'curva a la cual nunca
pudieron interrogar los mismos alemanes
pusieron en duda sus acusaciones
en febrero de 2003 no podría haberme
puesto de pie y decir que no había armas
podía decir llevamos a cabo 700
inspecciones y no encontramos nada y se
trata de profesionales todavía quedaba
una pregunta si saddam hussein realmente
se había deshecho de todas las armas de
destrucción masiva en particular
químicas porque no mostraban las pruebas
él le tenía miedo a ira pensaba que irán
se aprovecharía de eso era
pero para washington importaba un poco
los hechos acerca era saddam hussein se
había vuelto una obsesión
en ese momento los estadounidenses y las
fuerzas de la coalición estaban de las
primeras etapas de las operaciones
militares para el desarme de irak para
liberar a su pueblo aquí para proteger
al mundo de un gran peligro
p
washington y estaba en washington el día
de la caída de bagdad me acuerdo estaba
en la casa blanca el director de europa
me dijo sabe tomará mucho tiempo para
que eeuu perdone a francia yo le
contesté sabe tomará mucho tiempo para
que el mundo perdón en eeuu se levante
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
todo pasó muy rápido y se había
anticipado que la campaña militar sería
rápida la gran pregunta era qué pasará
después me acuerdo de haber llamado a mi
jefe general con tres estrellas el
comandante del cuerpo y le dije tengo
buenas y malas noticias me dijo cuáles
son las buenas noticias y yo les dije la
buena noticia es que ya controlamos naft
y contestó fabuloso felicitaciones
cuales son las malas noticias que dije
controlamos la caf que quiere que
hagamos donde están los tipos que nos
dijeron al igual que sólo debíamos
llevarlos hasta bagdad y que de ahí en
adelante se encargarían él dijo bueno
llámenlos lo hice y dijeron que todavía
se estaban organizando eso quería decir
que no había autoridades iraquíes ahí
para ayudarlos con eso
[Música]
todo el mundo pensaba que george bush
era un héroe y fue más o menos una
semana después de eso que empezó el
saqueo y los ciudadanos de irak se
dieron cuenta de que no había ninguna
autoridad ninguna y ahí fue cuando
realmente empezaron a hacer problemas
la administración bush no conocía a la
duda estaba guiada por una determinación
casi mística para sacar a saddam hussein
del poder y aún no había perdonado a los
que se interpusieron en su camino
las fonts
de un compañero más infancia fue objeto
de una campaña masiva a través de todos
los medios estadounidenses el pentágono
desinformaba de 100
francia le entrega armas a saddam
hussein para acabar con nuestros aviones
la falsa francia hace todo lo posible
para que nuestra operación no funcione
y
los estadounidenses nos prohibieron
utilizar la vía rápida de la ruta que
llevaba hasta el aeropuerto eso nos
obligaba a tomar la vía lenta en
promedio había una decena de atentados
al día ni siquiera los estadounidenses
tomaban esa ruta se desplazaban en
helicóptero y que estaban exponiendo
nuestra vida casi de manera voluntaria
pero una vez en el lugar los
estadounidenses se encontraron con un
país que debían gestionar el jefe de la
diplomacia colin powell y la consejera
de seguridad nacional condoleezza rice
presionaron a la casa blanca para que
asumiera sus responsabilidades
powell y condoleezza fueron los que
convencieron al presidente de que tenía
responsabilidades como potencia
ocupadora en virtud de los acuerdos de
ginebra y de la ley internacional así
que debía quedarse luego jerry bremer
fue nombrado y se volvió pro cónsul y
así sucesivamente
el exdiplomático paul bremer apodado
jerry fue nombrado jefe de la autoridad
provisional se volvió de facto el jefe
del estado iraquí recibió carta blanca
del presidente bush para llevar a cabo
la de basificación el base era el
partido único bajo la dictadura de sadam
husein un lugar de paso obligatorio para
cualquier cargo de responsabilidad en el
gobierno y en el ejército
y
yo estuve presente en una reunión antes
de la invasión de irak con el presidente
busca el presidente tome dos decisiones
primero de basificar y hasta cierto
punto
la segunda decisión era que lanzaríamos
folletos desde un avión militar para
decirle a los soldados del ejército
iraquí regresen a su casa
nosotros los volveremos a llamar
una de las primeras cosas que hizo
primer cuando estaban ir a actuar de
cierta manera reeducar esas dos
decisiones
y
él desmanteló todo el ejército y
recuerdo que uno de los coroneles me
dijo sabes qué significa eso eso
significaba que unos 50.000 soldados de
la guardia republicana habían regresado
a su casa con sus armas pensando ahora
me opondré automáticamente al gobierno
así de simple
jerry shoes
me dieron la orden antes de que me fuera
a washington gente que me la dio el
departamento de defensa y me dijo que
había sido completamente coordinada con
el conjunto del gobierno de eeuu
robert desmintió toda responsabilidad
pero dijo haber cometido un error
haberle confiado una parte de esa tarea
a los propios iraquíes
yo también fui uno de los miembros de
ese comité de basificación el programa
era importante porque era que estaba
gobernado por ese partido que era el
partido terrorista e dictatorial no es
correcto ni razonable que los miembros
de ese partido permanezcan libres
basso en alemania con el partido nazi
por eso era lógico y normal era natural
y necesario que hubiera un proceso de
aislamiento y de exclusión para estas
personas lejos de la administración en
el nuevo estado
hay personas que dan declaraciones
falsas sobre este tema dicen que esa
orden hizo que colapsara el gobierno
iraquí eso no tiene sentido la orden
estaba diseñada para afectar solamente
al 2% de los líderes del partido
y
de hecho uno de los resultados fue que
sacaron a los maestros pero los maestros
tenían que ser miembros del partido baas
para poder ejercer no eran una amenaza y
los niños no podían recibir clases
porque sus maestros habían sido de
basificados eso realmente fue un
desastre
no hay duda de que algunos de los
profesores que tenían un doctorado eran
básicas y algunos de ellos incluso
habían hecho su tesis de doctorado o de
maestría sobre los discursos de saddam
hussein tere salta actuaba en mayo
esther a esos profesores merecían
enseñar en una universidad teniendo una
tesis doctoral sobre los discursos de
sadam husein
robert premier para todas las semanas a
la oficina oval este responsable de la
cia le informaba al presidente bush
sobre la evolución de la situación en la
que una mañana premier se sorprendió al
descubrir que paul bremer se había unido
a la reunión
ahí estaba sentado paul bremer lo cual
era un poco incómodo porque básicamente
estábamos diciendo que las políticas
establecidas por el señor bremer eran un
desastre y que estaban llevando a eso
pero le entregamos el informe al
presidente y el presidente miró a bremer
lo recuerdo como si fuera ayer dijo que
piensa ábreme el señor primer dijo no
veo otra opción más que seguir el camino
en el que estamos en este momento y ese
fue el final de la reunión a partir de
ahí todo continuó
esa fue realmente la razón que llevó a
una gran cantidad de individuos a los
bears insurgentes o extremistas sabiendo
que también había otros por supuesto que
se volvieron verdaderos miembros de
al-qaeda
inicialmente al qaeda en irak fue
liderado por supuesto por zarqaui hasta
su muerte en 2006
pero es un hecho que estas dos
decisiones pero en revés es realmente
catastróficos y representativos de los
cuales nunca podremos recuperarnos del
todo
respecto de american channels respecto a
los generales estadounidenses que creen
que esto fue un error ellos no tenían la
responsabilidad que yo tenía que era
hacerlo bien y lo hicimos bien y esa
invasión tuvo repercusiones más allá de
las fronteras del país mientras los
estadounidenses concentraban todas sus
fuerzas en la batalla en irak la
situación se degradaba ampliamente en
afganistán
way
tal vez todos perdimos de vista al balón
y algunos en el seno de la
administración a mediados de 2002
empezaron a pensar en irak
y francamente pusimos a afganistán en
piloto automático y centramos nuestra
atención edad y dejamos afganistán al
aire
murieron muchos talibanes del resto
algunos fueron arrestados pero la
mayoría se dispersó que te disperse
la pregunta que nadie se hizo seriamente
a dónde se fueron donde estaban
y no desaparecieron de hecho era lo que
yo decía los militares decían salimos en
la mañana a hacer un patrullaje vemos
afganos en los campos que nos saludan
etcétera que nos hacen gestos amistosos
dinámico al regresar en la noche esos
mismos tomaron unos fusiles y nos
dispararon
cuál es la diferencia los talibanes son
también afganos y se mezclan
completamente con la población
cada año la seguridad se degradaba un
poco más cuando llegó a la casa blanca a
comienzos de 2009 barack obama heredó
una situación particularmente
preocupante tras muchas dudas por
involucrarse en un conflicto del que
quería salir el nuevo presidente
estadounidense decidió dar un golpe duro
para frenar la insurrección
barack obama ordenó el envío de 30.000
tropas a afganistán y dijo que
regresarían en 18 meses ok eso
obviamente era algo ridículo
quiero decir no los envíe o en pie los y
dígales que regresen a casa cuando
terminen el trabajo
en total más de 100.000 soldados
estadounidenses y decenas de miles de
hombres de la otan fueron desplegados en
el país pero los talibanes no esperaron
18 meses continuaron sus múltiples
ataques contra los soldados extranjeros
sabían que esas tropas se irían algún
día a diferencia de ellos
entretanto en washington poco a poco se
entendía que los paquistaníes estaban
diciendo a los estadounidenses lo que
querían escuchar
déjenme decir que pakistán tomó la
decisión meditada de ser parte de la
coalición
y de estar con eeuu de luchar contra el
terrorismo en todos los frentes
dondequiera que esté
pero claro por supuesto estaban jugando
un doble juego y estaban haciendo lo
suficiente para no tener a los
estadounidenses encima y para contar con
la ayuda de eeuu pero al mismo tiempo
algunos miembros del ejército pakistaní
estaban apoyando al talibán
viéndolo desde su perspectiva ellos se
estaban protegiendo a sí mismos porque
no podían estar seguros de lo que
pasaría en el futuro nunca hubo una
cooperación 100% definitiva de parte de
pakistán el error de la administración
bush fue pensar que sería progresivo
estaban satisfechos con el 30 a 40 por
ciento de la cooperación el principio
con el 50 por ciento nunca entendieron
que mientras que no hubiera una
cooperación total y completa el problema
se volvería a generar en donde se oxidó
un instrumento unos años el problema es
que somos occidentales y tiendo a decir
que justamente nuestro enfoque en la
capital en la construcción de un estado
central y ese es el modelo que nosotros
conocemos y sabemos que no somos capaces
de instaurar otro modelo
en este hay seis ellos se preguntaban
por qué no podemos ganar la guerra en
afganistán y yo les decía ganaron la
guerra al cabo de cinco meses se
cumplieron todos los objetivos todos y
luego se les ocurrió un nuevo plan que
consistía en convertir a afganistán en
la suiza de asia central
pero la administración bush descuido a
la reconstrucción en particular la
económica del país al comienzo del
conflicto sólo se le consagró 52 dólares
por habitante frente a los 814 dólares
en kosovo para los 1.390 dólares en
bosnia euros años atrás
[Música]
si button es aquel campo
si le entregan a alguien un fusil y le
dicen que trabaja para el estado pero no
puede alimentar a sus hijos que esperan
agua como dónde
y está prácticamente obligado a utilizar
su fusil para alimentar a sus hijos
eso es una gran pregunta que se plantea
en muchos países del tercer mundo
no vale la pena buscarle cinco patas al
gato
a dos mil kilómetros de ahí en irak el
controversial paul bremer entregó la
batuta y ahí los estadounidenses también
perdieron el control
el 22 de febrero de 2006 un nuevo ciclo
de violencia sacudió al país
[Aplausos]
sobre todo el bombardeo de la mezquita
de samarrá lugar histórico con mucha
importancia lo que desató algo que se
parecía mucho a una guerra civil con una
gran cantidad de muertos
en bagdad había en promedio unos 3.000
muertos al mes le tocó a mil más
de frente state se dirigen
de interjet
distintos estados en la región
incentivaron a los extremistas
para que llegarán desde distintos países
y entrarán gratis
es decir cientos o miles de carros
bombas
de stream est
y los extremistas lograron acentuar las
tensiones sectarias entre los iraquíes
sectaria en
función de gratis para contrarrestar
esta ola de violencia en la que se sumió
el país george bush llamó al general
petraeus y ordenó el envío de 30.000
soldados adicionales a comienzos de 2007
fue lo que los estadounidenses llamaron
el search
lo que hizo que el sol fuera un éxito no
fue el refuerzo de tropas sino el
refuerzo de las ideas fue la manera en
la que cambiamos nuestra estrategia y
nuestras tácticas en el terreno
fue un cambio de 180 grados en relación
con lo que estaba pasando antes del sol
era muy claro para nosotros que
necesitábamos volver a los barrios que
ya teníamos para asegurar a la población
y solo podríamos hacerlo viviendo con
las personas
[Música]
la guerra en irak fue también la
revelación de prácticas inhumanas
llevadas a cabo por el ejército
estadounidense
a 20 kilómetros al oeste de bagdad la
cárcel de abu ghraib fue utilizada como
centro de tortura en tiempos de saddam
hussein los estadounidenses tomaron el
control pero no cambiaron la naturaleza
del lugar
en la primavera de 2004 fotos y reportes
impresionaron al mundo fueron la prueba
de que los soldados torturaron y
abusaron sexualmente de los detenidos
iraquíes
[Música]
the great abu ghraib por un error
catastrófico es lo que nosotros llamamos
un error no biodegradable nunca
desaparecerá alves a quien describe en
algún momento pero esas imágenes esas
fotos siguen en la red se pueden
encontrar con facilidad
y eso seguirá siendo un incentivo para
quienes quieren criticar a estados
unidos para apoyar las actividades
extremistas
y eso galvanizó en particular a los
árabes sunitas una vez más para combatir
a eeuu durante los años posteriores a
esa revelación
de excavar
nunca antes en la historia de eeuu un
presidente del país había autorizado que
se torturaron seres humanos y eso fue lo
que hizo george w.bush bajo la fuerte
influencia del vicepresidente dick
cheney y su consejero
volamos la ley doméstica violamos la ley
internacional al torturar a las personas
no ha habido una rendición de cuentas
son criminales de guerra si eso
significa que debo ir a la cárcel como
criminal de guerra mientras ellos
también vayan como criminales de guerra
estaré satisfechos
en el curso de los meses el mundo y en
particular colin powell descubrieron que
los argumentos para entrar en guerra
presentados por la casa blanca y el
director de la cia george tenet eran
falsos
recuerdo que en agosto entró a nuestras
oficinas y dijo ya saben la última
noticia
georg todavía tiene esas fotos en su
página web
le dije fotos cuales fotos me dijo si
fotos de laboratorios biológicos móviles
siguen ahí y yo dije bueno obviamente
george todavía piensa que hay
laboratorios biológicos móviles power
dijo bueno creo que esa es la única
parte de mi presentación que se sostiene
porque todo el resto se derrumbó durante
el verano una semana después regresó y
me dijo george acaba de llamarme la
última parte colapso no no había
laboratorios biológicos y yo estaba ahí
sentado pensando bueno tú y yo somos
demasiado ingenuos ese es el verdadero
problema somos demasiado universo
si bien la política establecida por eeuu
en pro del caos los responsables
iraquíes que los estadounidenses
llevaron consigo no ayudaron a aplacar
las tensiones
el primer ministro malikí llevó a cabo
terribles actividades hectáreas que
volvieron a alienar a los árabes sunitas
y volvieron a hacer sentir desposeídos y
les volvieron a dar el incentivo para
hacer caer el nuevo irak en vez de
hacerlos triunfar
y por supuesto eso fue lo que permitió
que al qaeda ahora el grupo estado
islámico se reconstruyera en irak se
extendiera a siria se reforzará a nivel
militar y luego regresar a irak y
causará problemas tan significativos
estableciendo un califato con un cuartel
general en mosúl en el norte y por
supuesto con un cuartel general en raqa
city
por dios no sé qué está mal según su
punto de vista tal vez él no ve mal yo
lo veo bien pero qué hay de malo en lo
que hice porque trabajamos con armonía
en cada etapa trabajamos juntos logramos
victorias juntos contra el estado
islámico y el terrorismo para reunificar
irak
y
la situación oscilaría entre lo malo y
lo menos malo durante el curso de los
años sin embargo hubo progresos notables
como la realización de las elecciones
pero una pregunta seguía sin tener
respuesta la del pecado original de los
más neoconservadores de la
administración
[Música]
haití
es cuestionable creo que tal vez la
mayor pregunta de todas es
porque decidieron ir a irak
a este creo que sigue siendo todavía la
gran incógnita
por qué
jennifer no podía hacer casi nada no era
una amenaza para nadie en ese momento
bueno
no conozco a nadie que pueda dar una
respuesta con su incidencia a esa
pregunta
y algunos de ellos todavía creen que hay
armas
pero eso es una [__] locura disculpe
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quizá fuera
[Música]
por
qué m
cuando me nombraron director de la silla
el presidente me llevó a la oficina oval
y dijo que una de mis prioridades más
importantes era ir tras mi lado
entonces conforme un equipo especial en
la cia que sólo fuera trans bin laden
les dije que esa era su principal misión
y que debían darme reportes cada semana
sobre lo que estaba pasando
a punta de perseverancia este equipo de
la cia detectó al mensajero de bin laden
el hombre hacía sospechosos viajes de
ida y vuelta a una villa transformada en
fortaleza la edificación con muros entre
4 y 6 metros de altura estaba instalada
a dos pasos de una base militar en
abbottabad pakistán
el mensajero recorría de manera
sistemática al menos 150 kilómetros para
hacer una llamada
weaver observen de camps
andrews
estábamos observando la edificación y
vimos a un individuo de mediana edad que
solía salir como un prisionero al patio
de una cárcel caminaba en círculos
rápidamente y luego volvía a entrar y
recuerdo haberle dicho a la cia deben
hacer una identificación facial ese
podría ser vilar en describí vermont
y me dijeron señor director hay muros
entre tres y cinco metros de altura
realmente no podemos tomar una buena
fotografía
y les dije a todos he visto películas
donde la cia es capaz de hacerlo
la silla tenía fuertes sospechas pero
ninguna certeza barack obama decidió
correr el riesgo y autorizó la operación
un equipo de navy seals fue enviado de
manera clandestina a pakistán en
helicóptero para atacar el objetivo
sí
[Música]
esta noche puede informarle al pueblo
estadounidense y al mundo entero que
eeuu llevó a cabo una obligación que
mató a osama bin laden el líder de
al-qaida diez años después del 11 de
septiembre el principal responsable de
los atentados quedó fuera de combate
es importante refuerzos enviados a irak
y afganistán dieron la impresión de que
la situación era un poco menos
complicada sobre todo en irak
[Música]
creo que nos relajamos demasiado y salió
mal
nunca debimos haber permitido que se
estableciera el califato en la zona
norte de irak y no tenía sentido
mira lo que pasó con siria seguimos
luchando tenemos tropas allá las
personas todavía se están muriendo
state en carne
of fighters algunos estados se
incentivaron que decenas de miles de
combatientes extranjeros fueran a siria
e hicieran caer el régimen sirio
para eso utilizaron la frontera entre
irak y siria esa es una de las
principales razones para el triunfo de
los terroristas en irak
deseábamos que esas malas personas no
fueran tan malas que si eran buenas sólo
fueran buenas haremos un pastel para su
cumpleaños usted debe entrar y todos
comeremos un pedazo bum
ex miembros del régimen de saddam
hussein islamistas más o menos radicales
liberados de las cárceles
estadounidenses en irak encontraron un
terreno común se unieron para agrandar
las filas de al qaeda en el país
dirigido por abu musab al-zarqawi luego
las del grupo estado islámico unos años
después
[Música]
esther y lo que hicimos fue permitir el
surgimiento del señor al sahraoui y el
grupo estado islámico y eso permitió que
hubiera asesinatos caos y terror en todo
el país y permitió que el grupo estado
islámico volver a alzarse durante otra
década y finalmente estableciera un
califato
ahora por fortuna eeuu los combatientes
internacionales e iraquíes eliminaron el
califato pero no eliminaron al estado
islámico eso sigue siendo un problema
entre grupos terroristas confusión
política e influencia de actores
extranjeros irak estaba lejos de poder
volver a su estabilidad y soberanía de
antaño
y que te funcione irak era un país que
funcionaba estaba encabezado por un
dictador terrible había mucha corrupción
pero la corrupción que había bajo saddam
era un juego de niños comparada con la
corrupción que existe hoy en día
no fue un fracaso hoy en día el baby per
cápita en irak es cinco veces mayor de
lo que era en 2003
la mortalidad infantil ha bajado
drásticamente la esperanza de vida ha
aumentado aquí así que los iraquíes
están mejor ahora de lo que estaban bajo
sadam husein anders rasmussen
aunque los grupos terroristas que
atacaron la región a occidente como al
qaeda y el grupo estado islámico son
sunitas en washington algunos
neoconservadores siguieron pensando que
no era la principal amenaza
[Música]
los islamistas sunitas no tienen un
programa de armas nucleares tampoco
tienen un programa de armas químicas o
biológicas irán si el hecho es que la
capacidad para infringir un daño masivo
mucho peor que el horror del 9/11 y
mucho mayor que eso le corresponde al
país que desarrolle una capacidad
terrorista y armas de destrucción masiva
por eso irán es la amenaza central es el
centro rural
paradójicamente fue la política
establecida por esos mismos
neoconservadores la que reforzó a su
enemigo jurado
jon digo punto que cuando fui a estados
unidos me recibió john negroponte que
había sido nombrado director de
inteligencia nacional estadounidense
y también me reuní con colaboradores del
presidente bush
que me dijeron bueno cada vez oímos más
que le entregan e irak a irán en una
bandeja de plata lo que piensa sobre
esto
y yo les contesté que lo que me
sorprendía era que se estuvieran dando
cuentas ahora no
estadounidenses tenían la fuerza la
capacidad el dinero para estabilizar el
país para estabilizarlo alrededor de un
poder chiíta cercano
en el fondo hacían el trabajo soñado de
los iraníes
es un desastre geopolítico mayor irak
era un país era la barrera ante las
ambiciones iraníes y todo lo que ocurre
hoy en día en el medio oriente proviene
ahí si los saudíes y los emiratíes están
aterrorizados morirán es precisamente
porque ya no hay nada más no hay más
irán entonces se acercan a israel si uno
está en abu dhabi por supuesto que va a
estar preocupado por tener aire en
frente
la situación es aún más complicada en
afganistán que en irak los talibanes que
se habían evaporado en diciembre de 2001
ahora controlan casi todo el territorio
y ha retomado kabul incluso antes de la
salida definitiva de los estadounidenses
[Música]
y así estas versiones muy importantes se
nos olvidaron dos cosas olvidamos la
vida cotidiana y olvidamos el problema
de la droga
si no se erradica la droga no se puede
erradicar el terrorismo porque la droga
financia directa o indirectamente los
movimientos terroristas que cobran sus
impuestos sobre la droga del bien esto
no hay que olvidar que afganistán es el
primer país productor de heroína en el
mundo
también trate de hablarlo con el
secretario general de la onu y debo
decir que recibió un interés educado por
supuesto porque uno siempre es educado
en las reuniones internacionales pero no
hubo ninguna repercusión rigurosa a
pesar de la adopción de una constitución
con poder central el gobierno afgano
encabezado por ashraf ghaní nunca logró
imponer su ley en todo el país el ex
vicepresidente y unos con un y denunció
a esta situación unas semanas antes de
que los talibanes regresaran a kabul pas
de líderes y qué janeiro haiti fue
inmoral
hoy en día no hemos alcanzado un nivel
de autonomía a pesar de sus actividades
y de sus pérdidas nuestras fuerzas de
seguridad no son autónomas aunque estén
respaldadas por la población y esa es
también una de las lagunas de los
últimos 20 años
el gobierno recibe apoyo y toma acciones
a cuentagotas
y justamente le hice la pregunta al plan
y cuando fui a hacerle mi visita de
despedida le pregunté cómo veía la
situación y que pensaba sobre el
gobierno de un país donde el 30 por
ciento de hecho hoy en día más depende
porque está el día y la noche el 30 por
ciento escapaba el control del gobierno
y me dio una respuesta llena de
sabiduría
dijo que si miraba la historia de
afganistán desde hace 400 o 500 años
vería que ningún gobierno afgano ha
controlado jamás la totalidad del país y
sin embargo dijo en afganistán sigue
existiendo y seguirá existiendo siempre
la retirada de las fuerzas
estadounidenses decidida por joe bayrén
fue el último clavo en el ataúd de las
esperanzas occidentales y la sociedad
civil local 20 años después del 11 de
septiembre afganistán ha vuelto al punto
de partida
winston
en making surf
todavía debemos jugar un papel para
asegurar que irán y afganistán vuelvan a
ser una base de operaciones para el
terrorismo
pero
desafortunadamente cuando nos fuimos de
irak y los guías tomaron el control
eliminaron a los sunitas de las
operaciones en el gobierno y en el
ejército y rápidamente lo sunitas se
unieron con el grupo estado islámico y
crearon la fuerza que regresó a irak en
turba
en eeuu tuvo que volver a irak para
asegurarse que el grupo estado islámico
no controla en irak
debemos asegurarnos de no cometer el
mismo error en afganistán cannes
la administración bush llegó al mundo a
dos décadas de guerra a consecuencia
centenas de miles de muertos miles de
millones de dólares invertidos países y
una región cuya situación no mejoró y
una amenaza yihadista hoy en día
multiplicada
[Música]
estamos descubriendo que después de toda
una dictadura es mejor que una guerra
civil es terrible tener que decirlo
miren lo que pasó en irak sadam husseim
era un dictador atroz pero honestamente
alcanzó esas centenas de miles de
muertos warren y así debe ser
y ahí me arrepiento sí señor sí agregar
a mi casa
me arrepiento porque 4000 o más de mis
ciudadanos están muertos no puedo
imaginarme cuántos iraquíes de alguna
manera la situación es mejor ahora pero
el grupo estado islámico sigue ahí por
eso estoy horrorizado con las personas
asociadas con irak
y siento que tenía una deuda con mi
ciudad no tengo arrepentimientos lo
único que lamento es que no lo hayamos
hecho en 1991
desearía nunca haber tenido nada que ver
con eso cada muerte que ocurrió en irak
en el lado iraquí en mi lado
estadounidense en el lado británico en
los otros lados en los lados de la
coalición siento que tengo un grado de
responsabilidad por eso no es una buena
sensación
de esta atención donde usted no creo que
le siga dando suficiente importancia al
911 para entenderlo bien creo que hace
parte del pasado para las nuevas
generaciones
yo creo que las lecciones que aprendimos
se hayan tomado en serio
la prueba de eso es que todavía no lo
estamos haciendo bien en la guerra
contra el islam radical
podría hablar de boko haram podría
mostrarle atrocidades podría hablarle de
cualquier país y mostrarle que la
situación es menos estable ahora de lo
que era cuando me fui de la agencia en
2006 no estoy bromeando la banda de we
know cargo freighters el desagüe
sabemos cómo ir tras los terroristas y
matarlos pero hay algo en lo que no
hemos trabajado y es cómo prevenir que
los terroristas se vuelvan terroristas
es algo en lo que no nos hemos
concentrado lo suficiente
en eeuu no aprendemos las lecciones
hicimos un desastre matamos a muchas
personas dos millones y medio de
personas lanzamos más bombas sobre el
norte de vietnam laos y camboya que las
que lanzamos durante la segunda guerra
mundial y no aprendimos nada así que la
respuesta a su pregunta es que los
estadounidenses no aprenden nada
deberíamos llamarnos eeuu de amnesia
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
especial de reporteros el documental
recuerde que puede ingresar a nuestra
página web más 24 punto com para ver
esta emisión y las anteriores hasta la
próxima semana
[Música]